foreign
we've done these start doing these facts
of your friends segments and some little
inside baseball how it works is we have
a team meeting once a week or once a
month and we go through here's here's
what all folks are writing in and asking
questions about here's what social
medias are asking questions about and
then here are some trending topics
across the planet especially in the U.S
of things going on and so people want to
know Delaney what your take is on these
things and
I missed a meeting I was doing something
and
So today we're talking about on
everyone's favorite facts or your
friends segment
today we're talking about the rise the
global rise
of tarot cards let's do this
get your marble Reds and your uh tight
jeans and your mustaches it's time for
facts of your friends all right so why
in the world we talk about tarot cards
surprisingly and not surprisingly tarot
cards have seen a massive Resurgence
globally but especially in the U.S since
the pandemic kicked off and now they're
being incorporated into
psychology psychologist office in
counseling offices into anti-anxiety
responses into Christian faiths and all
sorts of faiths all over the place
they're all over social media Tick Tock
you can now schedule Zoom tarot card
readings across the planet so before we
get going listen listen
no one and I mean no one is gonna like
what I have to say about tarot cards
because I'm going to talk about all your
little precious everythings all of you
so listen I don't know anything about
tarot cards I don't know the history of
them I don't know where they're from I
don't know if they're like from some
occult I don't know one time on social
media I recommended that people like
that yoga was a good practice or some
there's some great research about yoga
and Trauma recovery and people wrote to
me like do you know yoga is from Satan
himself listen
I just like wearing my stretchy pants
and standing on one leg that's what I
like and so I don't they're
everybody just take it down 30 40 also
I'm gonna be talking about your precious
enogram and your essential oils and all
that so no Hogwarts spells cast on me
and no tarot card spells if that's even
a thing okay cool all right great I
entered this I got this topic they
handed me a bunch of uh
articles I entered this with the way I
end like enter all of these things with
curiosity not judgment I went in going
huh awesome to learn about not I'll show
them right one of those is very
open-handed one of them makes me an
idiot all right so here we go tarot card
readings all right uh 14 to 1500s about
suit symbols like they're cards they're
like giant playing cards if you will
um cups swords batons and coins
those will change your life and things
like Sun Moon Star Temperance death
traitor old man Wheel of Fortune 42
Chariot Justice love pope Emperor
impressed mount mount Bonk the fool all
these different cards okay
um and then in the early 1900s Arthur
Waite Pamela Coleman Smith they got
together and Drew what is now the the
more modern version of these cards okay
and they kind of they fell into the
occult World they started out as just
basically parlor games like we're
playing these like we're having some
drinks and we're playing cards
um I in my head it's like Texas Hold'em
in the 1400s and then over time they
had some mystical and divine properties
attached to him and then they turned
into this more occult thing because they
were like I'm gonna predict the future
like fortune telling right and then
different religious groups got all
worked up about it and then anyway here
we are so during the pandemic uh Sarah
Pulliam Bailey and her Washington Post
article says sales tripled during the
first year similar to what happened
during the 2008 financial crisis uh
sales of tarot cards I read multiple
articles and all of them made very clear
that the modern use of tarot cards is
not for fortune telling or for
predicting the future it's not for like
what should I do am I going to meet a
lover in three weeks or am I going to
get fired for my job that's not what
they're for they're about stories and
symbols which psychologically is a very
Union concept right uh and quite
honestly symbols and stories is
something we all do but that's a whole
other conversation Sarah Pulliam Bailey
says it's part of a wider trend of
younger Americans mixing and matching
different forms of spiritual or
religious practices with one another
not for trying to seek or meet the
Divine or to have a relationship with
God however you describe that but
they're trying to find some method to
the madness that is their life she goes
on to quote someone is saying more
people are now more interested in it for
the self-reflection or space to get
validation and Clarity verse hearing
you're gonna meet some hot stud in three
months get ready that's not what they're
for so she says they're great for
anxiety ah maybe I've got some issue
with that but they may not be predicting
the future but they do you can slow down
Shuffle look at the pretty pictures and
say oh yeah I'm overthinking this
so
if I think of tarot cards not as a
fortune telling device that's silly and
it's nonsense we all know that
but if I look at them I say it's silly
and it's nonsense somebody just cast a
spell on me just now they have they
pulled out their jungle any voodoo doll
and they're just jabbing pins in it
don't do that my life's sketchy enough
as it is be nice
but as a tool of reflection so this is
where I'm gonna make everybody
uncomfortable
I've always said any tool for reflection
at any time is good
I include in that Myers-Briggs strings
finders things anagram
um your essential oil anything that you
use
to codify and explain your automatic
default settings to things the stories
you tell yourself the roles you've taken
on in your life any of those things that
get that you look at and go huh I
usually respond like this and it gives
you pause and you think through why do I
respond and huh
why do I do that none of these things
have good science behind them zero as
reasons to I'm not gonna hire that
person because they're an Enneagram four
and we need a six in this role if you
treat it like that Bad News Bears dude
or if you're like I'm not hiring that
infj they're gonna fail at this job
that's discrimination that's silly right
that's silly but they are great tools
for reflection for asking yourself huh I
do respond like this more often than not
and I do have a tendency to fill in the
blank right those are good our culture
needs more reflective practices okay so
number two I got a line and did a free
tarot reading
I kept waiting for like the pit of Hell
to open up and get me it didn't I just
got tired because it was after nine
o'clock but listen I did it and it was
fascinating here's what it told me
one of the card the first card was I'm
gonna find a new love soon and a new
relationship is headed my way
it's so naturally I thought well I'm
married so that's not great
um and then I thought this my wife and I
have been going through what I would
call very significant transition over
the last six months I have a new
teenager I've got a first grader so we
are out of this half day stuff or out of
the kindergarten world and my career has
gone sideways my wife is getting
recognized at stores now apart from me
she's got people at doctors offices and
and and haircut places asking her about
the show which she doesn't listen to
right I am getting stopped in airport
bathrooms so our I'm getting we're
having family dinners and people
stopping so our life none this is bad is
well getting stopped in an airport
bathroom that's just super weird but our
life has changed it's shifted it's it's
and so we are uh it made me think back
to Estelle perel which he said
all great great I mean all adults have
three or four or five great loves in
your lifetime and if you work really
hard it's with the same person
it's so then I thought back oh yeah
we're entering into a totally new season
my wife is a different person now she's
the mother of a teenager the mother of a
first grader the mother of a guy who is
on the internet talking about sex all
the time
I am the husband to not a professor a
research Professor who's traveling all
over the country presenting research I
am the mother of a stay-at-home mom who
lives in the woods and who makes sure we
have eggs everywhere because the
chickens aren't dying and our life is
completely different and she's got new
ways of seeing the world and I've got
new experiences
and so then it made me think huh
I am going to get a new love I am I have
a new life my wife and I have introduced
stage and this reflective idea at my
kitchen table looking at an Instagram or
whatever it was tarot card
was actually really healthy it was good
for me it actually gave me pause it's a
conversation I'm gonna have with my wife
later
number three in my new book I have a
chapter called choose belief I make the
case both through ancient wisdom and
through science
I believe that one of the cornerstones
of having a non-anxious life is you
cannot
self-actualization cannot be the
Cornerstone because the the self can't
hold the universe it can't hold it it's
not strong enough and where the more we
try to shove the self into the center of
the planet the more anxious it gets
because it's saying I can't hold I can't
hold
and so you got to choose some sort of
belief and belief I think often starts
with reflection number four I was having
I mentioned this to a caller earlier
um
connection I was having breakfast this
morning with my buddy who's a physician
and we were talking about how I've
noticed over the last five to ten years
the more I go to the doctor when I go to
the doctor they're touching me more not
inappropriately but they always have
their hand on my arm or my shoulder
and I they looked me in the eyes better
than than 15 or 20 years ago
and I always leave the doctor's office
so calm even during hard conversations
you're gonna have to have surgery I
leave so calm
and then I got to thinking about the the
research and for counselors and
therapists and psychologists
people are so desperate for someone just
to listen to them not waiting for their
turn to speak but just to listen and say
how are you tell me about your life
that I'm wondering if the rise of tarot
cards is giving people an excuse very
similar to the questions for humans it's
a conduit towards human connection I
want to look you in the eye and you
listen to my stories and you listen to
my life and you tell me about things
that I'm not seeing in my own self the
rise of coaching the rise of therapy all
those things and I'm wondering if tarot
cards the rise of them are is just a way
for finally someone's listening to me
the last here's my final thoughts these
can be super dangerous
and stupid quite frankly if they use
them in the wrong way there's reams of
data on priming I call it nudged
learning or expectations and learning
um Luna colloqua's done a lot of work on
here we're always absorbing cues in the
environment how we should respond to
something
what that means and a lot of this is
unconscious so if I think I'm going to
get a response I may be leaning that way
if I think this card is going to tell me
if I should break up with my girlfriend
or my wife and it says you're going to
be finding new love
my body can run down that lane before
I've thought it through so if you're
going to use tarot cards or anything
similar for secret messages from the
universe you're putting yourself at risk
for making rash unwise unsafe decisions
and I personally don't put a lot of
stock on these things because I am rash
and I make rash decisions and I'm a mess
and so I don't mess with them for that
very reason
um if you're going to use them for fun
or to jump start conversations or
questions or about important topics or
just something fun for friend like
Dungeons and Dragons or online gaming
whatever other things you're into
knock your lights out don't use them as
a tool for big life decisions
now you're gonna get yourself in a lot
of trouble doing that okay
um priming is a real and unconscious
thing so Kelly that's my thoughts on
tarot cards
you know you had me a little nervous
earlier because you wouldn't tell me
the angle you were taking
I thought that was fantastic
tarot cards it is America let's do this
I'm a
Queen of Wands
I think that's a thing no